we were found with technology and we
forget to to just look at each other can
be really really intense experience
really deep and me from it's really
emotional I see people it's being true
it's being authentic and we are not used
to do that we wear a lot of mask right
in the society I saw fear today and I
saw it because i have here as well I saw
joy I saw love I saw doubt that's where
the interesting part is for me you get
to have a glimpse at what's going on
inside that you don't necessarily admit
to yourself that's what connection is
all about like a lot my friends they're
so afraid of like kind of like missing
the perfect knives missing the perfect
snapchat story missing the perfect
tumblr picture they're so like busy
capturing things that actually mr.
things are actually important in life I
think we create also a little bit more
understanding between people yes you
very powerful moments with a few people
you